papano
皆さんこんにちは山中俊治です
まあ今写ってるのは僕はで題してきたものをいろいろなんですけど
フリーのデザイナーとして今日なもんで男子てきて
まあグッドデザイン賞の金賞をもらったものや
ニューヨーク近代美術館のパーマネントコレクションになったもの
でも
今日はその話ではなくて
研究者がギャラリーを持つということ
というタイトルでお話しさせていただき
3年前に東京大学の生産技術研究所というところに来ました
そこでまああの多分よくこうちょっときれいな建物
研究室を持つことができたんですけど
その研究室のアマタクム確認
一つギャラ頭があったんですね
今日はそのギャラリーを使った私の研究室の活動を紹介させていただこうと思っ
生産技術研究所に来てここは宝の山だな
思いました
先端技術が形を与え題が与えて欲しがってたくさんよこだわっているんです
デザイナーとしてこれにロードたーーーーいくという形で
形を与えて皆さんに体験できるようにして展示していくそういうことをやってみたら
面白いんじゃないかなと思います
ここに上げてあるバナーは2年前からやってきた6つの展覧会のバナー
最初にあった展覧会は
生命の片鱗というタイトルで1ボロっぽいロボットの展覧会を行いません
まあシビラ振る舞いをするロボットと1000人ぐらいの人が
a
体験することができましたん
始めたので難解だったので不安ですたんですけども多くの人に楽しんでもらったと思い
ます
次になったのは
マテリアルの建設地という絢爛階です
2つのテーマが一つの展覧会になっていました一つのテーマはチター
資産というと大変高価な筋力だと皆さん思っていると思うんですけれども実は地上で9
番目に多い件数です
宣言する静電数方法さえ洗礼されてしまえば実は日用品としてふんだんに使える金濃く
なっている
a
東大の岡部達先生はそういうことを研究していて
彼と一緒にね
遅沢が日常品になっていった社会というのを提案する
展覧会でもありましたそれから3区にていく
まあ何でも出来る魔法の機械のようにですね
一次選定されたけどね
ちょっと復旧してみると思って何もできないんだよ
岐阜マシンでもでだけど親父にたじゃなきゃできないカタチが結構あるんですね
そういうものを
作ってみていますでダイバーたちと一緒にこういう形は3 d プリンターがでわっ
で
次にあったのはベーグルという展覧会でした
まあこれも学生たちが作った色々なおもちゃ
もう白いもので遊んでもらう day 3プリンターで作った新しいて代わりや生き物
っぽいロボットやいろんなものを楽しんでもらうという点だに変わりました
5日間しかなかったんですけどそういう時は1400人くらいの人を迎えることができ
ました
それから去年の6月に行ったのはデザイン5人っていう対極の
我々がずっと進めてきた美しい時速プロジェクトの見学会です
ん
割れるん
なのでは高校生の頃からう
我を
味噌食って外観と思います
ブーブ c 存在かあっニェッに行きまーし
大丈夫ん
まずの走る様にコープする人との新しい未来が見えてくる
最近我々はまで順番外せる
俺を呈すタンカーすること心なるん
彼女の足を直接けーい
茶道使ってそれを3 d 声で体力だけしていますん
れそうすることで多くの白い感じ感じで
優れた美しいずを供給そうワゴンなん
この研究は老朽大学の兄残し0
えーーっと am
ん
ま連れて行くいったならではの複雑な骨ドナ早くのような繊細な形状が
美しさ火を再建する構造最適表示してい
フェーズはここまでなんですけども実は先日ようやく
走行テストを行うことができましたね
本店ランカー1800人の性が来てくれてさまざまな私たちの義賊の点を見てくれると
思います
プロトタイプは単なる10分機ではありません
ユーザー体験を事前にそのを提示して人々に
科学技術がもたらす価値を共有してもらうためのツールです
てそれをギャラリーという場で展示することによって技術と人々をつなぐことができる
のです
一番最初のを a
エレガントせるという展覧会を紹介させてくださいデザイナーと愛をエンジニアの研究
者が一緒になって新しいものづくりに取り込めました
一般的にはその場合はの
エンジニアリングというのはえっ
まあ食ったては ips 細胞で臓器を新しく作るとか
遺伝子改変で新しい作物を作るとかそういう育てる系の
a
テクノロジーなんですけどここにはこの研究者たちは
西郷を機械の布巾のように扱って人工物を組みかける研究をしています
その研究者と一緒になってさまざまな研究を行いました
学生たちがバー細胞の培養の仕方から学ぶというようなことを貼ります顕微鏡を使って
出たりするなんていうも初めてのだけ
細胞としてはマウスの細胞を使いますその細胞の
例えばですねええゲイルコラーゲンゲルのまあ dinks の細胞を植え付けて
日で休場のものを作ります直径100ミクロンほどの小さな急ですけれども
こんな感じ
これを作るとまぁ細胞とそれをがせるための培地栄養素が一緒になった小さな粒が
できる
でこれを型に入れて成形することで
ば市東最高額を均質にこう等分された立体を作ることができます
で
まあどっちもデザイナーたちは様々な日台を作りました
みんなに生きていく
つまりこれはまああの体としては西区
じゃないんですけどこの中で最高は生きてい
ある学生はそれを人の形にしました
繊細な骨格を与えて人の形に先ほどの最後ビーズをモールとしてこんなものを作ります
これもね
生きているものか1夢のでしょうかっていうと研究者の答えはノーです
テープであの生物学的な定義では生物じゃないよね
でもその中で最後は生きていってえーっ
細胞が成長するまあ細胞っていうのはお互いに引っ張り合ったりして徐々に就職するの
で
その骨格を引っ張るんですねで一つ一つ
つ異なる姿勢を取るようなつまり微妙に個性が生まれてあります
細胞札状に成形する技術なんかもあります
この写真の真ん中の金融の部分がまあ最後が違って並んでいるんですけども
コラーゲンのチューブの中で細胞は生き続けます
この研究はそもそも例えばいい朱鈴をその分泌細胞をこれくらい状にして
あのー生物のカードの中に入れることによって糖尿病
表事業するっていうようなものなんですけど
うちの犬ガードデザイナーはこんなものを作っていました
どっかで見たいっていうものみたいですよねでこの身体の中でこれ細胞は生きてました
でもこれも生物ではないと思います
で
こんな研究もありますこの
とても小さな薄い膜がその展開図を作ってその上で細胞を培養しますそうすると
spoon 9ジョイントの部分にピタ最高はそれを引っ張るように動くのでこの展開
図を組み立てることができます
そうやって一体ボニー実態を作らせるみたいな教育を終わります
細胞綿状に並べて人工皮膚を作るという研究も会話を進めています
渋谷切る8名の法律の人に
泉を入れてもらいました世界初の人工皮膚の位で続きです
まああのこんなふうにいろんなことをやっくんでトライしているんですけれども
その研究環境もデー対しています
様々な柄を
装置を提案しました実際に動くものを作りましたのでどこで売ってんのってこれ見た人
たちが効くんですけれどもそれは
まだまだあの
西これから作っていくものになりますメーカーと一緒に開発できます
まあ研究者の声を経ながらハッピーなんかもデザインしていません
多くの下に1400人くらいの人に
ガールバイオエンジニアリングという馴染みのないテクノロジーに触れてもらうことが
できました
さあ最後に東ミーティン未来の展覧会をご紹介しますメイキングメイクプロトタイプの
政策や町っていうタイトルで来週無数あ今週の水曜プロ9月1日から今は出てない海で
ありますのでこれ
ぜひ見に来てください
研究者の皆さん
研究成果を発表する場は決して
ローン分野
朴派レンスだけではありません
ギャラリーというプレゼンテーション空間で発表することもぜひ考えてみてください
それは取得ととつなぐ記事ストップして一つの以上新しい
もう一つの扉があると思います
ここに力ここにいる皆さんでもしかしたらバイオエンジニアリング面白そうと思った人
がいるかも知れ渡れ見て光栄と思った人もいるかもしれん
でもたぶんその人は未来を考えています
だとすればまた一つ私の企みが成功したことになります
今日はどうもありがとうございます